welcome back everybody our recap moves
to Connecticut where Sandy Hook families
are on the hunt for punitive damages
against Infowars host and conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones last month Jones
faced a near billion dollar payout to
over a dozen plaintiffs the filed
defamation suits after Jones called the
2012 Sandy Hook Elementary School
shooting a hoax on his programming this
followed a similar suit in August out of
Jones's residing City of Austin Texas
where a jury awarded one set of parents
49.3 million dollars in this case the
nine-figure award applied to
compensatory damages but now the
plaintiffs are seeking additional
punitive damages using the Connecticut
unfair Trade Practices Act as a means to
do so in a hearing on Monday the parties
argued over who has the bigger burden to
prove here
we don't think it's our burden to
produce evidence from which the we don't
think it's our burden to prove How Deep
The Well the plaintiffs seek to draw
from is they want to draw from the well
it's their burden they chose to play
fast and lose with numbers uh with a 550
million dollar or 550 million impression
multiplied in some loosey-goosey way
toward you know by the mo the the 100
million to one billion number attorney
Maddie got the corporate rep to adopt
that's not our problem if Mr Jones was
genuinely concerned about how this uh
any punitive award would impact his
business he could have sought an
opportunity to present that evidence the
problem is that uh Mr Jones doesn't want
to present evidence of his true
Financial condition to this court or to
any Court
all right let's break this down Rich can
you explain to us what we're talking
about with unfair Trade Practices how
does something like that support
punitive damages which we know are meant
to punish someone
right well the Connecticut unfair Trade
Practices Act or katpa as we call it is
a unique theory in this case in addition
to defamation and intentional infliction
of emotional distress and the statute
has much wider punitive damage
possibilities under General Connecticut
Law for a tort like defamation or
emotional distress the punitive damages
would be very limited but which has to
do with deceiving the public for
financial purposes would open them up to
really a much higher punitive damage
number
here's my problem Terry with all this so
the amounts that Alex Jones has to pay
in Texas and Connecticut I think we
could call them astronomical I think
that's probably a good word to say if we
add then punitive damages to the
Connecticut case I just feel that these
are all going to be reduced on appeal
right I mean doesn't he have a strong
argument that these numbers are too much
here for what he did these numbers are
really high Jesse and honestly he
defaulted and the hired the award in my
opinion the better for him it could be
completely vacated so you know you have
to look at whether or not he's going to
be able to pay this and whether or not
on appeal an appellate court is going to
say this is astronomical you shouldn't
have to pay this it's not supported by
the evidence and all of that could very
well in fact happen and right now with
the award now that we have for the Texas
case and now the award for the
Connecticut case punitive on top of that
is going to make it even more
astronomical so I definitely think that
this is in his favor I think he's going
to let it go and appeal and I think
we're never going to see the end of it
and frankly he probably doesn't even
have the money the highest award so far
the defamation case that I've seen is
over 220 million dollars so this is far
in excess of even that I always just
wonder if he actually fought this if he
fought the liability portion what would
that trial of look like I think it would
have been fascinating from a legal point
of view but that's my two cents